من بيروت ينضم الينا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العميل الياس حنا العميد
الياس حنا حينما يقيل رئيس دوله تخوض حرب
رئيس قائد القوات المشتركه ماذا يعني ذلك
عبد الصمد هناك عده اسباب لهذا الامر وكان
ما يريده بالمعنى العسكري لا يوافق عليه
رئيس الاركان المشتركه هاي واحد اثنين قد
يكون من ضمن عمليه التطهير والتي طالت
الكثير من القيادات السياسيه والعسكريه
وزاره الدفاع بموضوع الفساد ثلاثه قد يكون
بسبب الفشل في اماكن ما معينه وانا اعتقد
لهم ان الرئيسكي يريد بناء مجموعه
مهمه ان كان في السياسه او الاستخبارات
وحتى في العسكر متجانسه معه الى درجه مهمه
قد ترضي اولا الغرب لانه اليوم هناك ما
يقدم لاوكرانيا على ان تكون ضمن النيتو
ضمن حلف النيتو ولكن دون تطبيق البند
الخامس وحتى دون نشر قوات من النيتو على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه عده اسباب قد تؤدي الى
هذا الموضوع ولكن التغيير اثناء الحرب هو
جزء يعني يدل على شيء كما يحصل من الجهه
الروسيه ايضا تماما يعني توقيت التغيير
خاصه انها القوات التي يراسها هي مرتبطه
بقياده العمليات الشرقيه اوكرانيا تحديدا
نعم رئيس الاركان للقوات المشتركه وهو ما
يطلق عليها بالانجليزيه مياده
يعني هو من يدير العمليات الجويه البريه
البحريه السايبر وما شابه وهو الذي ينسخ
في هذا الموضوع قد نكون في مرحله جديده
مياده وصول الدبابات الخطط المستقبليه قد
يكون هناك خلافا عليها وانا اعتقد اليوم
انه هناك مرحله جديده قد تستلزم قيادات
جديده او قد يكون بسبب فشل ما اوعدم
الموافقه على اهداف الرئيسكي في المرحله
القادمه ما الذي في هذا الاطار نقراه من
الجانب الاخر الاعتماد على المسيرات التي
بدات تصل حتى الى حدود كيف
المسيرات عبد الصمد هي استمرار
الاستراتيجيه معينه بدات منذ سبتمبر نعرف
ولكن اليوم حسب الاستخبارات البريطانيه
منذ 15 فبراير لم نشهد مسيرات وكانت تحليل
انذاك انه نفذ المخزون من المسيرات شاهد
واليوم الجيش الروسي يعيد تخزينها ولكن
دخل شيء جديد على المعادله عبد الصمد هو
تسريب الخبر من انه الصين مستعده لتزويد
روسيه بمئه مسيره مشابهه تماما ليشاهد 136
هذه مرحله وقد تكون نقطه التحول في الحرب
الاوكرانيه
جبهه باخمه تحديدا يعني القوات المواليه
لروسيا تتحدث عن ان المدينه اقرب للتطبيق
والحصار المشدد عليها وهي تحت السيطره
الناريه وفق تعبيرهم الروسيه كيف تقيم
الوضع في ضخمه
يبدو مياده ان حسب الخبراء يقولون ان هناك
خمسه محاور هجوم في الشرق للسيطره على
اقليم الدومباس ككل لانه الهدف الرئيسي
للرئيس مبوتيين بخموت عاجلا ام اجلا قد
تسقط من هنا السعي الى
كما قلت ان هناك دبابات تبدا وكان وهي في
خلفيه محمود ستكون خض الدفاع الثاني وكل
هذا باستراتيجيه اوكرانيه تقوم على ما يلي
الصمود اكبر وقت ممكن استنزاف القوات
الروسيه مع خسائر كبيره بانتظار ان
تستكتمل منظومه الدفاع والتي قد تكون
مرتكزه على الدبابات القادمه من الغرب
شكرا جزيلا لك من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العميد اللي يسحب